i'm proud of you
it takes courage to do this [ __ ] yeah
i had to muster it up [ __ ] with that
damn tree it's wrong there's a round
then i looked down a storm look at you
stupid dude you got on christmas socks
in march
you're wearing green christmas time oh
god
all right so welcome back norman uh glad
to be back you were
missing you were missing in action for a
while here yeah
you were supposed to show up a couple
couple weekends ago for another update
but
you did show and uh that told me exactly
what was going on
you tell me what you've been through
well um
i lost my sister dear dear
sister and um she died in uh auto action
yeah
died in a very vicious auto accident
um where her head was severed
and you know
you went to the funeral did the funeral
and uh
got got people that just want to land
blast you and
things like that and culmination of that
and
trying to deal with the emotions and
it just i couldn't take it anymore so i
went and i got high as a [ __ ]
i continue to get high i'm thinking
about time is it
i think about four hours out four to six
hours i'll have like
24 hours um
of course i'm ashamed about it i think
with me i put
i put a little bit too much on myself
it's not so much that i have
that that i got this feeling it's just
that
okay today's okay just keep going
forward i try
my best with the positivity and
everything within me
even my wherewithal and i questioned
myself
about five nights ago where the [ __ ] is
your wherewithal
what the [ __ ] are you doing for christ
sakes right now i have on christmas
socks
in march and some people might deem that
funny but
to me it's that's a [ __ ] shame
um i don't use anything as an excuse
i believe this excuses of skins of
reasons wrapped in lies
you know and basically
i used because i wanted to
because the evidence is is quite clear
um
driven by a negative emotional status
driven by the loss of a loved one
the disease itself is unique enough to
come together and combine itself
and [ __ ] me up
[Music]
coming to see you i went around the tree
for four times because i didn't want to
come here
shame yeah i um
i'm probably really not gonna like any
of the comments
that are negative but that's okay
because i gotta stay in that mind frame
that it's going to get
better i remember you were talking about
two steps forward one step back
well goddamn and i'm tired of stefan you
know
i mean and and some people may say well
if you're so tired why
why don't why don't you just stop
goddammit is not that
damn easy i think it's the hardest thing
anyone ever
could ever could ever do you know
job-wise everything's just fine
you know there wasn't a cloud on the
horizon that's the big book of alcoholic
anonymous states and
unconsciously i knew it but it didn't
surface
because i got real shaky before i drank
i drank first and then i went and got
some cracking
i've even tried crystal meth i don't
like that [ __ ]
but you know it's um
as devastated as i may be i got to pick
my head up
i got to keep going forward i got to
muster up the wherewithal
i got to keep praying i got to still
keep believing i
still got to have that faith you know
that non-knowing
untouchable faith i have to have it you
know i was put in some situations while
i was
you know running around where they
weren't death defying
you know but i had to fight you know
i don't like to fight because when i
fight
every time i fight i see my mother
laying in a casket
and that's all i remember
um i see mom and it's like a
black it's just this guy told me he said
man
he said dude i've never seen anybody
fight like that
i said what happened he said what
happened
he said look this guy was laying on the
ground with blood coming out of his ears
and his nose
and i got the hell away from over there
um i could have killed that guy
all about drugs he wanted a hit and i
told him no
i remember that
what if the situation was turned around
what if that would have been me what if
i would have hit my head on the pavement
that was all she wrote
so i just um
at this point i really don't know
but i know i'm gonna know soon
i really thank god for keeping me uh
with some semblance of sanity while i
was out there and
last night was the first time i really
had a comfortable sleep
because i've had to keep one eye open i
was
down here on skid row for a minute and i
went to other places because i didn't
want anybody to find me and lo and
behold
when i come back to [ __ ] still
roasting you you were in a
in a put you up in a place for a while
yeah yeah yeah i was there
yeah i was in a place before i moved
into the uh the transitional home
and everything was mine you know i even
seen a drug deal in the motel
go down but i'm like hmm
it's not that i just you know brush it
off like [ __ ] i got this
no i was like wow you know that's
something
no thought
i'm not gonna ask myself why anymore
because god damn i know why
bottom line is i'm an addict the bottom
line is i have
a mind is you may seem how you may
you may see people may think that i'm
brilliant as hell
yeah i have some books since
and i have some street sense
but i have to really put this in my mind
there's times when i have
no sense
my mind has the capability of [ __ ] me
without my permission
and it's unique that it always does this
when things are okay you understand that
everyone does though
and i'm beginning to learn that because
i seen a a couple of people that were in
recovery
with me at certain times and uh
one of the guys we sat down and he said
man i'm tired of doing this i said i am
too but i can't stop
he said you too yo i said the moment i
said i want to stop
i'll get up walk down the street and
hear somebody say hey look
do this do this
there's not too much to say
but i know it's a whole lot to do um
got some bereavement time so i'm okay
as far as that's concerned and then i
asked myself last night do i really want
to go back to the job
do i really need to go back so you
didn't lose the job no
do i really how did you not lose your
job
um because they knew about them i told
them flat out about your bereavement
and uh they said okay well
you're new but you know they offered me
some some time off some bereavement time
and i was like cool
i mean because i work for a company man
that's really cool because your sister's
death they gave you time off
yes got it and um i mean you know i went
to the
i think i'd text you i went to the main
office and everybody stood up and
flocked to me and i'm like what the [ __ ]
is going on well somebody seen my story
and they told someone and they told
someone
and they all watched it and a couple of
ladies were in tears and they just
looked at me like
you know you're so encouraging
you're such a breath of fresh air you're
such a light
wow there's many and you still
are many positive things that i receive
there's times when the negative
dominates
and this was one of those times
i'm gonna pick it up it's gonna get
better
may have another setback i don't know
i'm not gonna deal with the predictable
mind
but i am gonna take things a hell of a
lot slower
a hell of a lot slower to give myself
ample time to
understand that [ __ ] you're not
out of the [ __ ] water just because
things are okay
i know i put too much on myself
i don't believe ego and pride set in
pride only set in when i just uh tried
to walk down this damn street and i was
i was like no man you want to disappoint
mark but see it's not
on the bus ride over it's not about
disappointing people and it's not about
disappointing me
it's the fact that i gotta understand
that [ __ ] you're an addict
and this [ __ ] happens
maybe there'll come a time where it
won't happen again
we take the together with the sweet we
do what we need to do
and we keep moving forward that's all i
can do
losing your sister is a serious
you know it's a hard thing to go through
and a relapse is almost inevitable you
know
i mean it's just and you were close to
her yeah
yeah i um at the funeral ride
it was the first time i thought about it
i was like oh [ __ ]
and i said a prayer and it went away it
was a fleeting thought
but that's the [ __ ] that got me
that one right there
when it came to a point where it came up
in here
i think you called me from detroit or
houston where you were
true yeah and you know you look at
you you're doing fine yeah god
damn
if i could turn my damn leg around i'd
kick my own [ __ ] ass
you know with these christmas socks over
man and
you know i just um
if i disappointed anyone i'm not gonna
say i'm sorry
and i'm not gonna apologize but i will
ask you to keep continue to pray for me
um for anyone that's gonna say a
negative comment
it's okay
but always be mindful to see to it that
your own house is in order
to myself i want to say forgive yourself
norman
pick your shoes up put them on
and let's walk again
just a step back yeah
kids don't know but they do know oh yeah
babies mothers both of them call me i
didn't answer the phone
my oldest daughter's mother wants to
marry me
she says you're the only man i've ever
loved so what if you smoked up three
houses and four cars
i'm like what the [ __ ] you mean so what
she said oh yeah yeah i was mad at you
but i never should have left you because
she brought me home my car was in the uh
in the auto repair place and
she picked me up from work and she took
me home to an empty house
and i'm like i turned around and looked
at it she just had to she said i can't
do it no more
i said well what about alexis she said
i'm gonna take care of you everyone
about me i want to see the baby
we'll discuss that and i'm like no don't
leave she just knowing i have to
that was one of those heart-ripping
moments in my life
but i loved her and i still love her um
good woman you know she did
i haven't looked for my mom in
relationships
but that motherly instinct i do because
i think it was taken away so
so quickly and uh she's that type of
woman
while she'll lay in bed cuddle with me
and i like that [ __ ]
you know i'm just a big ass [ __ ] baby
and i like that [ __ ] she would cook food
and bring it to me and
you know and the [ __ ] thing about it
is
when i first tried to talk to her she
wouldn't say [ __ ]
i said hello and she walked right past
me i'm like yeah okay
i think a couple of days went by and
hello seen her again she walked right
through
what the [ __ ] is wrong with her somebody
had to put my macaroni with the cheese
down
so i told this little girl that stayed
across the hall from me this apartment
built into detroit
because i was having a house worked on i
said hey you know that big like scared
that thick light-skinned girl upstairs
she said yeah who normally you like her
don't just hear
we'll give you some candy and i'll tell
us okay
for four days i sat there and waited at
the time that i knew [ __ ]
she didn't show her lo and behold one
day i'm going to check my mail
here she's saying
[Music]
i said pardon me she said so you're the
guy who gets little kids to do their
dirty work huh
i said what do you mean yeah that little
girl told me you like me why did you
tell me yourself
you ain't got the nuts to tell me i'm
like uh yeah you know now i ain't
telling my dad
i was okay i said well hi she said hi
and that was it beautiful woman
inside and out
i remember when they said our daughter
might not live
because she was born in six months
she'll be 33 in october
if she can fight to stay alive so can i
i just realized that [ __ ] she fought
grew up to be a beautiful woman
product of me
yeah there are signs where i just steal
it man you the only person ever
allow me to yeah i just feel like real
comfortable with you man
yeah you know i'm not you know
intimidating my you know i
don't have that fear for me man is he a
[ __ ] you know i
went through that [ __ ] oh you're just a
comfortable person and i
it's not so much that i owed it to you
but i owe it to myself
i i hold this sitting in the seat right
now i owe it to me i think these talks
help you
they help people listening they're going
through similar things
and they just help move the needle
forward in terms of
humans dealing with these kind of issues
honestly like yours and patrick's and
many of the other people i interview it
really just helps because honesty i
believe
is the solution yeah and i was talking
to a
our buddy a mutual friend yesterday he's
like
he said dude you know honest
[ __ ] i've ever met in my life
he said you just tell it i said well
what do i do sit up and tell a bunch of
[ __ ] lies
for what what is it going to get me this
is what happened
this is what the [ __ ] is going on
you know it's almost like smoking a lot
of cracking being in the sun
you know you're running around trying to
find some shade you can't so you're
standing and sweating like a
[ __ ] it was like the reaction
that all your co-workers had
when they saw your videos yeah it wasn't
negative
no they were like it's positive and the
president she was like
she said can i talk to you i said sure
we stand on talking like about an hour
and a half
you know and because i don't put my
schooling
on my resume because every time i put it
on there i've only gotten
well i got six jobs with it disney
uh you see ford general dynamics
disney universal who the [ __ ] else was
talking about and warner brothers
because my specific i have a power
resume and then an administrator resume
my power resumes with schooling and
everything i've done as far as computers
networks security implementations that
stuff like that
my other one is just administrative
stuff like when i work for
uh the sros and schedule housing trust
administrative stuff all this stuff so
[ __ ] time i went into a small
job with that resume like hell no you
take my [ __ ] job i don't want
your [ __ ] job
you know so
we'll muster it up
we always do
you got what it takes yeah
yeah i've got to move pretty well [ __ ]
i'm gonna
i can't go back to transition you use
once that's it
so where will um
[ __ ] my six i was in a [ __ ] tent for
the first time in my life
i was slitting the tower no god
[ __ ] rain goddamn tents leaking over
here sleeping over here sneaking behind
me
i'm like what the [ __ ] i just laid there
horrible
yeah then i'm like god damn how did they
do it but i stayed in the [ __ ] tent
stayed in the [ __ ] one thing
that was really unique about it i was
smoking crack and usually
in a closed environment like that i
would get extremely paranoid
not at all not at all
i think it was kind of i ran into a
buddy of mine
you have to go to vegas
is this recording yeah i can take stuff
out though
he gave me something because he had to
go
and i think that's one of those things
that kept me okay
it was you know then it dawned on me
do you know what the [ __ ] he did with
his [ __ ]
do you believe you need to get rid of
this [ __ ] and i did
i had it three days but what if i would
have got caught
with drugs and a handgun that's not mine
and everything would have been pinned on
me that would have been sad
i'm sitting in a [ __ ] sand
quitting looking stupid as a
[ __ ]
trying to keep my sanity damn that was a
loud one
yep thanks man yeah thank you man
no problem no problem at all
you're very brave oh
gotta keep it in here it's gonna be okay
you're gonna be all right yeah
all right thanks for coming in thank you
for having the courage to come in
no problem i'm proud of you wow